كشف مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليام برينز ان الرئيس بايدن طلب منه قبل
الحرب الذهاب الى كييف لاطلاع الرئيس
ليلنسكي على اخر المعلومات الاستخباريه
التي تشير الى احتمال تخطيط بوتين لضربه
خاطفه للسيطره على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
طلب منا رئيس بايدن ذهب الى كييف لاطلع
الرئيس زلينسكي على احدث المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه والتي اشارت الى احتمال
تخطيط بوتين للضربه خاطفه من حدود
بيلاروسيا خلال بضعه ايام والسيطره على
كيف بشكل مفاجئ من خلال انزال الجنود في
مطار هوستميل ودخول العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اعتقد ان الرئيس زيلينسكي فهم ما هو على
وشك الحصول وما الذي يواجهه كانت لدى
المخابرات الاوكرانيه معلومات جيده لكن
معلوماتنا ساعدت الاوكرانيين ايضا في
الدفاع عن بلادهم في وقت مبكر قبل بدء
الحرب
شاهدت خلال السنوات الاخيره كيف قل صبوتين
عدد مستشارين اذ كانت دائره مستشاريه
تخبره بما يريد سماعه وكان هذا احد العيوب
في صنع القرار الروسي